les policiers ont colère ils manifestent
dans plusieurs villes de france ce mardi
mobilisation deux jours après le verdict
du procès de viry-châtillon un verdict
qu'ils estiment trop clément il dénonce
l'acquittement de huit prévenus
les cinq autres ont été condamnés à des
peines allant de 6 à 18 ans de prison
devant le palais de justice de paris sur
l'île de la cité plusieurs centaines de
policiers se sont rassemblés à la
mi-journée rassemblement qui a suivi
notre reporter tonnes abonnés entre 150
et 250 policiers se sont rassemblés
devant le palais de justice de paris à
l'appel de plusieurs organisations
syndicales pour faire part de leur
mécontentement notamment après le procès
qui s'est déroulé ce week-end la cour
d'assises dès mineurs a condamné cinq
jeunes à des peines allant de 6 à 18 ans
de réclusion pour avoir brûlé des
policiers dans leur véhicule c'était à
viry-châtillon dans l'essonne en 2016
huit autres jeunes ont eu eux était
acquitté c'est un verdict qui ne passe
pas qui provoque énormément de colère
ici dans les rangs des policiers je
propose d'écouter quelques uns des
représentants syndicaux que nous avons
pu interroger avec baptiste gosselin le
symbole qu'est données d'une façon notre
c'est le chaos
le chaos aujourd'hui vous interpeller
des individus qu'on 20 25 30 antécédents
digne du catalogue de la redoute comme
on dit si bien dans le jargon et au
final derrière vous allez même pas en
prison et encore vous rigoler quand vous
voyez un policier parce que vous savez
qui vous arrivera rien donc ces
individus n'ont pu n'ont aucune notion
la justice doit faire son travail
appelons un chat un chat il faut qu'elle
arrête d'être laxiste elles doivent
sévèrement sanctionné et il n'y a que
comme ça qu'on rétablira la situation
nous demandons à ce que lorsque les
collègues sont victimes
il ya des juridictions spécialisées qui
se met en place pour ce genre d'affaires
pour juger ce genre d'affaires il faut
bien connaître le métier de policier
son quotidien ce qu'il vit donc voilà
nous demandons aussi de protection et
reconnaissance et j'en profite de votre
antenne aussi pour vous dire que nous
demandons aussi que des peines minimum
au moins soit immédiatement donné
lorsqu'on agresse un policier mes
collègues n'en peuvent plus quand ils
contrôlent on les traite de raciste
quand ils subissent des violences ils
ont un ou deux jours d'itt et et tout le
monde s'en fout ils peuvent poursuivre
les gars ils sont insolvables dans les
cités on peut plus y rentrer
on se fait laminer on a des blessés tous
les jours on a des morts on va aller
jusqu'où comme ça on va avec un petit
peu de saupoudrage peuvent être sain
camping flic si on est 50 mille
interpellé dégâts forme et dehors le
lendemain à quoi ça sert à quoi ça sert
d'avoir plus de bleu un mécontentement
qui vous l'aurez compris dépasse le
simple cadre de cette affaire de
viry-châtillon c'est plus généralement
une forme de sentiment d'impunité que
dénonce ici les policiers ils ont été
soutenus ce midi par nicolas dupont
aignan le député de l'essonne justement
qui est venu donc apporté son soutien je
vous propose de l'écouter
j'ai été révoltée par cette décision de
justice qui n'appliquent pas la loi
libre aux juges de décider qui est
coupable ou pas ça ne regarde pas en
revanche à une échelle des peines il ya
un code pénal et quand des juges
condamnent à six ans de prison à 18 ans
des personnes qui ont voulu brûler vif
des policiers et que le code pénal exige
au moins 20 ans 30 ans la perpétuité
je dis pourquoi pourquoi quand on veut
brûler vif un policier on a une excuse
c'est insupportable et cela a des
conséquences incalculables sur la
sécurité de nos policiers qui sont en
danger maintenant les policiers
demandent donc des actes forts de la
part des pouvoirs publics
il ya notamment le beauvau de la
sécurité également la loi sécurité
globale qui sont censés être des
réponses de la part du gouvernement à
quelques unes des problématiques avec
aussi dix mille policiers qui devrait
être recruté jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat mais tout cela est parfois
jugée comme insuffisant et surtout trop
tardive par les policiers qui regrette
qu emmanuel macron phase de cette
thématique de la sécurité
un acte politique à un an de l'élection
présidentielle c'est un peu trop peu
trop tard pour un certain nombre de
policiers ici avec lesquels j'ai pu
échanger